uh
[Music]
camera we'll pick it up
i can't really see it but if i keep oh
my god i'm gonna burn him
[Music]
very very stiff
arms no wiggle
[Music]
and the motors are very hot
[Applause]
coming to you guys from
sunday afternoon hike because uh so i i
owe
kind of everybody a uh reason why
i haven't really been available making
much videos lately
and that's really because covid is an
incredibly incredibly popular time
to have any dental work done
not just crowns and fillings and whatnot
but
lots of surgery lots of missing teeth
full mouth rehabs
lots of stuff so uh i don't really get
paid much
by youtube like it's basically a dinner
once a month
and um the store the fpv cycle store
me and my partner josh don't take a dime
out of it yet
i mean we're not planning on it anytime
soon because we're 100 focused on
developing
also i have a very long list of things
on my desk
that i have not had a chance to review
that dji review and the emacs review
as you could tell i barely knew what the
name of that emacs thing was
because i just haven't had much time to
mess around with this stuff
because it just isn't worth my time at
the moment when i have
so much work to do at actual work that
pays me
so uh this so one thing i do want to
point out is that this
is a one axis gimbal made by maker boys
these guys have made a couple of
products in the past that have been
pretty interesting
and hold on while i pass these other
people and so i pointed out because i
really like these guys
and i'm really sorry that i've had this
thing for like i think like eight months
now and i haven't
had a chance to even put it on a quad
anyways this video
is about ramp-up power specifically
i felt like rampa power was a
very costly finding to find but also a
very valuable finding to
learn what it does and how it works at
least in part
and i feel like it is a significant
enough finding to
make a video roughly about tuning
with ramp up power in mind so if you
guys know me you know that
number one i hate tuning and number two
i suck at tuning i'm the kind of person
that will spend
a couple hours tuning a quad going
through 10 15 batteries
just to end up with something that is
significantly worse than it was when i
started
i don't think that my experience is
unique i think it's an experience that
a lot of people can um relate to because
tuning has just gotten so complicated
over the years
and it's it's for good reason and for
annoying reasons
but it has gotten complicated and the
emphasis has moved off of pid tuning
because we now understand more about
what's going on and
the information coming out of the gyro
not like we didn't understand it before
i don't even write the code so i don't
understand anything i just
kind of work with it and i'm just giving
you a view from outside in and a huge
disclaimer before i talk about anything
uh this may or may not work for your
quad may or may not work for whatever
you're trying to do
i found it working really well for a
number of quads that i've been
trying to deal with and so let's just
jump right into it so
rampa power is known as startup power
in bl heli s it's known as ramp up power
mbl heli32
i believe the two do exactly the same
thing in the recent bluej firmware ese
firmware
it has been broken out into three
settings
startup power ramp up max and ramp up
min
startup power is the power it uses to
actually start the motor spinning if it
gets stuck
on grass or if it's just just from
from zero or if it's got like something
stuck in the motor like gravel or dust
or something
and then minimum ramp up power as far as
i understand it
is the minimum power that the esc will
drive to the motor
in order to ramp it up from low rpm
to higher rpm and it's very specific low
rpm to high rpm
and maximum ramp up power is the maximum
power it'll use to ramp it up from low
rpm
to max rpm so the esc has kind of a beat
on
what the bell is doing and where the
magnets are spinning and where they are
in their rotation
rotational axis and
it can decide how much power might be
needed to
spin the motor up from low rpm to higher
rpm
based on the amount of electromagnetic
force that's being
fed back to the esc from
from the actual motor bell spinning and
passing by the stator poles which is
generating
a backwards electromagnetic force and so
here is the very basic finding this is
not correct
in any technical sense this is a very
layman's
understanding of of how it may or may
not work
again i don't know if this will work for
your quad it definitely won't work for
all quads but i'll
discuss more of the implications about
it after i try to convey what i
i think maybe the easiest way to
understand this so
ramp up power is how much power
the esc uses to drive the motor bell
up from low rpm to high rpm
if the ramp up power is reduced
it somewhat loosens the the
response to pid inputs not stick inputs
or anything pid inputs
if the ramp up power is increased it
kind of tightens up the response
to pid inputs if the ramp up power is
too high
you could get an not an over response
from the pid
inputs but it'll respond so quickly that
it'll overshoot and then you'll get this
feedback loop where the quad will kind
of flutter up to the sky
an early sign of this is when you do
rolls and flips
you might hear this kind of robotic
sound from the motors
which if you've built a lot of quads you
may
relate to noise in the system or
vibrations in the system which
you are going to try and figure out how
to resolve oftentimes you'll look at the
black box
and you'll see that the lines are all
over the place and you can't even begin
to figure out what on earth is going on
let alone what to do to try and resolve
the issue and if you drop the pids to
almost zero you can pretty much solve
this issue
this fluttering issue or this this motor
whiny noise issue and uh the quad will
fall like crap because the pids are at
zero
if the ramp up power is too low the quad
will generally just feel
loose it will feel like it doesn't
really have
great prop wash handling and you cannot
tune the pids
to get them anywhere close to what you
might want them to be
if you had a nicely tuned quad that
performed as you wished
so i will call this the response to the
pid
loop however i would say that
i think that this setting along with
dmag and
motor timing need to be set before you
even begin to consider your filters
before you even begin to consider adding
a capacitor or a bigger capacitor to
your esc board
to kind of manage the electro the the
noise feedback electronic noise feedback
coming from the motors
because you can actually forego the need
of a capacitor
in some minor sense by reducing a ramp
up power because it also reduces the
backwards electromagnetic force coming
into the system and it reduces the whole
the noise in the whole system
so the quad that you saw flying at the
beginning
was a 300 gram 5.25 inch
2204 2800 kv quad on
3s which these numbers don't really
add up to a quad that beta flight or any
flight code really wants it wants a quad
that's around 500 to 600 grams it's got
a 2207 2306
with five inch props and it's going to
perform great on stock whatever you put
it on and
any frame you put it on all those quads
will perform great the problem comes
into play
when you start running setups that are
kind of a little bit outside the
performance window
that betaflight or any flight code
typically wants
now this is not a foolproof way to
improve things
but i have found that it can improve
things significantly
on quads that i even thought were flying
well so what this
could do or what i found that it seems
to do is that it kind of
slides the quad's performance up and
down a scale
where you could reach a zone where
beta flight or any flight code will be
more comfortable and then
the default pids will work better and
it'll be
way easier to tune your filters and
you'll get lines in your
black box that makes sense and you'll
know what to do with because they
actually make sense and they're not all
over the place with no explanation
so if you've ever flown a quad
or tried to build a quad that's like
super tiny like a three inch
on 6s that's super light you may have
noticed that it flutters to the sky or
has just extreme noise or it's
impossible to tune
or the quad just generally has no power
because the escs are just
super reducing the power output because
it doesn't know what to do because
there's so much noise in the system
it's as simple as just reducing the
power up timing and that's what i found
fixed the issues with the most recent
setups that i've been trying on three
inch
if you're flying a quad that's seven
inch or above and
it doesn't have the power output of a
typical five inch which
kind of almost anything larger than a
five inch quad will have a
lower disc loading ratio or power output
ratio or kind of like all the ratios of
performance
are worse when you kind of go up beyond
five inch
in most cases unless you do something
very special or specific to get the quad
to have better performance than
than would be typical if you just ran a
typical setup i'm trying to mitigate
those people they're going to say oh but
my seven inch fly's incredible on
whatever default
okay i'm glad that your quad fly is
great but in reality
most of the time you'll build the
typical 7-inch and it'll fly worse than
a 5-inch quad no matter what you try and
get it to
do with your tuning or filters or
whatnot and this is a way to actually
drastically improve the performance on
my own 7-inch quads
i just ramped i increased the ramp up
power and the overall
response to the pid loop and the
response to
everything that was happening on the
quad improved drastically even the
throttle pump issue
is drastically improved on betaflight
and emu flight no matter what you're
running so
if you're running like a centilifter rig
and you're dealing with
this hefty quad that is lifting
something that
it really doesn't want to lift you could
find some pretty significant
improvements now a pretty
big warning here if ramp up timing is
a ramp up power is too high or too low
or if it's outside of what
the system might want it to be you could
run into desync problems
you could run into uh motors that don't
even spin
or you could run into uh slipping
problems where the quad just starts
yawing out of control
this is true of default ramp up power as
well and this is where
there's a giant wrench thrown into the
equation because
depending on which esc you use the ramp
up power performance
varies so on some eses primarily hdl rcr
eses
so far that i found from talking to like
100 people about this issue
uh their ramp up power performance is
actually
lower on the say six or seven esc's that
have had these issues
is lower than most other eses
but on some of the t-motor eses
we found that the ramp-up power
performance is actually
higher than the defaults on most esc's
all of them are set to the same default
all of them are going to be set to 0.5
default
but the overall performance output is
going to be
less than the 0.5 or greater than the
0.5 and now it's really windy
this video has already gone on longer
than it should have gone
but i'll point out one other advantage
here
if you're running a quad that has low kv
and you want to run it on lower voltage
consistently like a 6s quad that's that
you're going to be running on 4s
almost exclusively or most of the time
you could actually turn
up the ramp up power and by doing so
the quad will fit the pit loop better
and it'll be like you're flying a quad
that is appropriately
tuned for the voltage that you're
running or vice versa
if you're flying a quad that's like 2500
kv and you're gonna run 6s on it
you can actually reduce the ramp of
power and it can
it's not going to have the same effect
but it'll be if you have
issues running it at 6s it can help with
managing the tune of a quad that is over
kv for the uh
setup that you're running for the
voltages you're going to be running and
the the lower that that
actual variation is a little bit
different because uh it really depends
on a lot of factors because when you
have too much kv
the overall torque in the system is a
little bit different uh but when you
have too little kv
the torque in the system can can vary as
well but it's much more manageable if
you go down in voltage it's much harder
to run higher voltages with
higher everything because of all the
noise in the environment that you're
running it in
so basically i hope that the fact that i
wanted to spend the time even though i'm
just trying to pile up my time and
triple booking myself
to make this video about essentially
tuning i still don't really tune my pids
i have tried here and there
and i will adjust them you know a couple
notches i'll try to use the sliders here
and there
sometimes i get improvements sometimes i
don't i'm pretty sure that's typically
what everybody runs into as well
give this a shot i think that rampant
power is an incredibly important
setting to adjust before you do anything
else
and i'm really surprised that
the kiss esc's don't even have this
setting in them and i suspect that
they'll be adding them soon because if
we're all going to be running these 250
gram
6s or whatever quads on whatever motors
uh we're gonna have issues which i can
run into issues
no no doubt we're gonna be running into
issues like i've been building these
sorts of things for
years and a lot of the quads just
haven't worked at all and i haven't
known how to get them to work
so i just gave up and threw the quads
literally just threw the quads away
because i was so frustrated by them
so yeah brush your teeth floss them
have good oral hygiene because um if
kova taught me anything
it's that um people have really
have a really difficult time keeping
their teeth in good shape
so please heed these words and floss
your teeth thanks very much for watching
bye